we're gonna kind of wrap up this section
right now with one last little piece of
the book here and this is one of the
guys named lavender last name lavender
he gets killed and the lieutenant takes
the blame
himself he feels that that blame and
part of it he kind of blames on his his
thinking about his girl back home Martha
and he's thinking he wasn't doing
everything he could do and what could he
have done better and where did he let
his guys down and what he could do
different from now on
and I'm going to the book he loved her
but he hated her no more fantasies he
told himself henceforth when he thought
about Martha it would be only to think
that she belonged elsewhere he would
shut down the daydreams this was not
Mount Sebastien it was another world
where there were no pretty poems or
midterm exams a place where men died
because of carelessness and gross
stupidity kiowa was right boom down and
you were dead never
partly dead briefly in the rain
lieutenant cross saw Martha's gray eyes
gazing back at him he understood it was
very sad he thought the things men
carried inside the things men did or
felt they had to do
he almost nodded at her but he didn't
instead he went back to his Maps
he was now determined to perform his
duties firmly and without negligence it
wouldn't help lavender he knew that but
from this point on he would comport
himself as an officer he would dispose
of his good
pebble swallow it maybe or use lease
trunks slingshot or just drop it along
the trail on the March he would impose
strict field discipline he would be
careful to send out phalanx security to
prevent straggling or bunching up to
keep his troops moving at the proper
pace and at the proper interval he would
insist on clean weapons he would
confiscate the remainder of lavenders
dope later in the day
perhaps he would call the men together
and speak to them plainly he would
accept the blame for what had happened
to Ted lavender he would be a man about
it he would look them in the eyes
keeping his chin level and he would
issue new SOPs in a calm inter pearl
impersonal tone of voice a lieutenants
voice leaving no room for argument or
discussion commencing immediately he'd
tell them they would no longer abandon
equipment along the route of march they
would police up their acts they would
get their together and keep it
together and maintain it neatly in a
good working order he would not tolerate
laxity he would show strength distancing
himself
so he falls back on what we fall back on
all the time on discipline on standard
operating procedures on maintaining
everything in good working order and one
of the things that you can see here in
people we get this too is you'd think
these guys are in Vietnam of course
they're gonna be paying attention of
course they're gonna keep the weapon
your weapon keeps you alive in a
firefight of course you're gonna keep
your weapons clean but he as the leader
he has to lead and I think that's a
common misconception and we do talk
about it all the time and it's one of
the most frequent questions I get asked
like well you know in the SEAL Teams
you've got everyone's motivating and
everyone's focused and it's a
life-or-death you know so they're gonna
stay sharp and they're gonna fall
procedure no matter what and you know my
team's not like that in the business
world or you know people I work with are
like that and the best teams they only
follow that procedure right because
they've got leaders that are stepping up
and making it happen and and look we
have some amazing people in the SEAL
Teams just like we have some amazing
people in the military in Army and
Marine units and other Special
Operations units etc but even with life
or death on the line people get
complacent people start letting the ball
drop not cleaning their weapons when
they need to or not falling a procedure
or letting their guard down because well
we've done this operation a dozen times
and nothing Bad's happen so nothing
Bad's gonna happen right that's it's
like this common human emotion that you
just make these assumptions and so the
only way that units are gonna stay
focused and not have that happening when
they've got good leaders they got a
fireteam leader in charge these four
guys to step it up and making sure that
these guys are squared away and staying
focused they've got a you know they've
got a squad leader making sure that his
squad is squared the LPO leading petty
officers out there making sure that guys
are dialed or not cutting corners I mean
I always saw that with guys you know
we've been these type of overwatch
positions you got like some of them had
like one stairwell in and out and
someone's gonna watch that stairwell
someone's got to have a weapon and
looking down that stairwell
for 72 hours yeah and so you know
hopefully we can rotate some guys out so
it's not just the same guy but but even
so if you it's gonna be several hours
that you watch them down that stairwell
and it's boring as hell right and guess
what you're the only guy watching the
stairwell and everyone else got their
backs to you so if you're not doing your
job you're gonna people get shot in the
back and yet if what happens
hey I've been here I've been on the
stairwell Hey look man doesn't we've
done this operation dozen times or we've
been in this building multiple times
nobody's ever come up the stairs I've
been sitting here for hours on end like
hasn't happened so you people will fall
asleep people will stop paying attention
and only if you've got good leaders who
are gonna go check on that guy and make
sure that he recognizes that listen
everybody's dependent on you you know
not only you're gonna get killed if
someone slips up the stairs but the guys
people gonna get shot in the back and
yeah they were depending on you to have
their back and it requires those good
leaders at every level stepping up but
going to check it on that gun if he is
tired you can't say wait rotate him out
put somebody else in there but it
requires leadership at every level so
even with life and death online people
get complacent and this really goes to
what you and I talk about all the time
which is what does it really mean to
take care of your people you know that
here well I want to be liked you know so
I don't want to be a real hard-ass and I
don't want to you know I don't want to
like you know I I don't want to push too
hard in that direction or like if they
cut this corner maybe it's not that big
of a deal and obviously you can go too
far in that direction right but you
become the slave driver but but are you
really taking care of your people if
you're allowing them to cut some corners
that they shouldn't be you know are to
get complacent when they shouldn't be
and the answer is no of course not
you're setting them up for failure and
so you as a leader have got to step up
and and make sure that your peer you
know the peers around you if you're not
a leadership position but certainly as a
leader make sure that your team and
those around you or toeing the line and
following those standard operating
procedures and achieving that highest
standard possible because that's what is
gonna allow them to stay alive on the
battlefield and ultimately accomplish
the mission and certainly dominate and
win on their battlefield anywhere you
know in business in life yeah you can
definitely see that but all the things
that
lieutenant Krauss rattles off that he's
gonna now start imposing he's gonna
start taking care
he thought he was taking care of his men
before by by letting them have dirty
weapons and not hounding him about that
by letting them drop gear on the trail
by not sending out flank security
because it's a pain in the ass he
thought he was taking care of his guys
and he got one of his guys killed and
that is exactly the point when you're
taking care of your people that means
you're taking care of them that means
you're holding the line you're holding
the discipline and you're making sure
that they are as safe as you can
possibly make them while still
accomplishing the mission and that is
the that's pretty much what we had for
this book by the way again it's called
Tim O'Brien the name of the book is
called The Things They Carried
definitely a solid read and and I would
check it out and echo will have it up on
the website and yeah I know
for those of you they're gonna come at
me and say it was a fiction book so now
you're gonna start submitting to me
every fiction war book that's ever been
written I don't know there's some damn
good ones out there and there's probably
something I'm gonna end up doing but
yeah this is one of them
that is and again it's it's it's it's
fiction but clearly it's based on
experiences and it's in and once again
you can see that even though war evolves
and war changes the the fundamental the
fundamentals of human nature in war
don't really change I'm I'm not into
fiction books I don't remember the last
time I read a fiction book I'm gonna
read that book design that immediately
resonated with me it puts me back in
those just the sights and smells and
them and the stuff that we carried and
opens up so you know it's just I look I
look forward to digging into it and some
details a good one and you know that's
the thing when when you are dealing with
these books
and you start to really
really listen to them and read them
there's just there's always so much more
than then you get out of it the first
time you go through it so that's why for
me you know reading it and then going
through it again and then sitting here
and reading it and and now when I put
the headphones on and read it it's they
definitely they definitely hit you and
you get more out of them in my opinion
no doubt there's something magical about
putting the headphones on you know cuz
you you read a couple those excerpts and
we were talking about this over the last
couple days and what the park is gonna
be about and it did not it did not you
know what's sitting here listening to
you read it with a headphones on it's
like takes me immediately back to Ramadi
thinking about the stuff that we you
know the things that we carried with us
and the moon dust that we patrolled
through and those smells and sketches
and they eat and frankly I'm I'm pretty
eager to go back and get something right
now I'm ready to make it happen